bonjour je m'appelle au fil il ya je
pense vous reconnaitre ophelia est un
être numérique dont l'intelligence
artificielle s'abreuve de ses
conversations avec des humains pour se
développer
déjà elle connaît félix leclerc moi mes
souliers ont beaucoup voyagé
son créateur le musicien je vais pas
chaque pense que très bientôt aux
filiales ses rejetons passeront pour des
humains avec l'entraîneur de défense
ophelia est une des neuf installations
de l'exposition humains présenté au
centre fuit tout tourne autour de la
question suivante jusqu'à quel point la
machine deviendra humaine
tout ceci a l'air de la réalité
virtuelle la technologie devient de plus
en plus confortable et réaliste est
vraiment aucune des années
éventuellement on se rendra peut-être
pop à la matrice tout à fait mais c'est
vraiment versac ensemble comment ferais
tu la différence entre le monde du rêve
et le monde réel
en attendant la matrice vincent morisset
a filmé les mouvements de trois
chorégraphes dont louise lecavalier pour
que vous entriez dans son corps le
système d'intelligence et retient elle
va chercher des images celle des moments
des fractions de seconde qui ont
vraiment existé un studio l'alter ego se
met à faire ce qu'on fait en temps réel
et l'idée c'est ça c'est de retrouver
leur le point la rencontre entre est
entre les deux puis de voir aussi
comment les lèche actes chacun des
chorégraphes ont imaginé sa potentielle
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
aussi un jour changer votre odeur cette
machine créer un parfum hyper
personnalisé à partir de vos réponses à
150 questions
la formule est complexe et nécessite
quand le flacon et 200 ingrédients
je pense que c'est l'avenir du parfum
entre les casser
et voie pour l'avenir du parfum l'idée
c'est de donner vraiment
je dirais la capacité de choisir pour
soi même de ne pas forcément suivre ce
qu'une marque vous propose
on n'arrête pas le progrès dit l'adage
est aujourd'hui que ce soit avec ou sans
casque de réalité virtuelle
tout semble permis est ce que tu sais
pourquoi les humains sont si cruels
envers leur planète ici pour louis
philippe ouimet radio-canada mourir